[Music]
Valona
these guys are taking this personal you
were only supposed to create a diversion
Roman that was complete destruction what
you want from me a Roman beers man is
what I do please - hey
- what say - bombs away
[Music]
you know what I like about you dawn your
genuine outlaw but your family hell of a
job brother we get back to the base
beers on me it's about to go up against
the only thing they can't handle you
did you ever think you'd betray your
family the way you did today Dominic
Toretto just turned on us oh well will
you look at that I don't know why he's
doing this
that wasn't dumb she's the very
definition of itec terrorism now she's
working with your guy I think I found my
team this should be interesting
[Music]
when I got
[Music]
ouch this is impossible
which is why you gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum we took longer than I expected
if you got a catch dawn
you guys are gonna work together
surprise I just for love I've been
waiting for this we got a tank is wrong
[Music]
I don't know the old Dom is in there I
don't give a damn I'm taking you down so
right oh let's play
[Music]
shooting at me I don't know maybe cuz
you're in an orange Lamborghini
[Music]
we are about to go on
see we're going to need a bigger truck
[Music]
you're gonna turn your back on family
[Music]
you